each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so very happy to have Mike Hamburg
who it was an undergrad here at a
Harvard and then they then went on for a
PhD at Stanford where he did some nice
walks like circular secure encryption
and efficient non pairing gay identity
based encryption and I also hear that is
a good chess player and I don't know who
you heard that from not really anyway
and but indecent program as well is that
also inaccurate it's it's accurate and
if it weren't I wouldn't admit it
yeah so this is joint work with Dan
Binet okay so this is a variant of
identity based encryption so in identity
based encryption it's sort of like
public key encryption but the basic idea
is that your public key is your name or
or any other string but some say
uniquely identifying string so as a
concrete example of this as always in
crypto Alice wants to send a message to
Bob so she encrypts it just using his
name and so you notice here that Bob
doesn't have intrinsically any secret
like he didn't generate his name so in
order for him to read the message he's
gonna have to get a secret from
somewhere so there's this other entity
the the pkg that holds which stands for
a private key generator who holds sort
of a master secret key and after Bob has
appropriately proved that he's Bob to
the pkg or I've done something else
out-of-band the the pkg we'll send him a
secret key that corresponds to his name
and then he can use this secret key he
just has to do this once he can use the
secret key a number of times to read
messages that are sent to him so this is
this design was proposed by Adi Shamir
in 1984 but it wasn't until 2001 that it
was built independently by Cliff
out of GCHQ and by Dan Binet and Matt
Franklin and so most implementations of
this that you'll find are based on the
Binet Franklin design and they use sort
of elliptic curves and bilinear pairings
as as their functionality in this talk
also uses elliptic curves and pairings
so in any case follow following on
mostly to the Binet Franklin work
there's been sort of a cottage industry
of at least what Dan calls adjective
based encryption and so some of these
are changes to the security model so
like anonymous ibe is a change to the
security model where you don't want
people to be able to see what the
message is - some of them add delegation
like hierarchical ibe there are some
that add sort of fancy models for
deciding under what conditions somebody
can read a message that you send a lot
of this is the work of Brent Watters
he's the W and most of these and yeah so
there are all sorts of different things
but the important takeaway from this
slide is there's a million of these and
they all have a separate construction
and what's worse they all have a
separate security model so despite the
fact that if you read one of these
papers you can sort of predict what the
model for the system and its security is
going to be
they're all sort of defined separately
and proved separately so the goal here
is to define a unified security model
that describes all these systems or at
least most of them and then an including
support of the variant security models
and delegation and so on and
additionally to design a toolbox that
enables you to build these systems
without being a cryptographer not not
necessarily all the systems above but
sort of many systems that have similar
attributes and this is a very flexible
tool box so you can build you can have
more adjectives than the other
adjectives based encryption schemes
really this doesn't solve faith based
encryption so the model for this this is
sort of true actually but I'll get there
at some point so the model is based sort
of on lattice based access control I
would call it lattice based encryption
but that's something else and and so I'm
trying yes a different kind of lattice
and so I'm trying role based encryption
for the for the name but that might
change so the idea here is that you have
some sort of hierarchy of identities or
roles as they're called and there's a
sort of blue arrow between them colors
show up kind of anyway there's a blue
arrow between them which means that the
see is oh for example using her core her
secret key she can create a secret key
for the VP of Finance and the VP of
engineering and they can create keys for
Carol and Finance and David engineering
risk
actively so this hierarchy doesn't have
to be a tree just this one happens to be
a tree but and it doesn't actually it
doesn't have to have a single root and
although the model sort of us it's
actually it's an either/or so it might
be that there's somebody under both the
finance and engineering or something and
then either either one of those VPS
could create that key it's an or yeah
yet these so that the arrow means sort
of can delegate to or has power over or
something like that yes yes the positive
light to cast this in at least depending
on your your corporate IT policy is that
there's implicit escrow built into this
model also so if you want to avoid the
problem
we now have a mom right so when you
encrypt in this model let's actually
just forward the slide 1/2 a slide so
when you encrypt in this model you
choose a policy from some set of
policies and the policies also
participate in this partially ordered
set but the important thing to note is
that the policies are just their strings
or some some there are there are objects
in some abstract set of policies that
doesn't have any information that's
derived from secrets in it instead
there's sort of one master public key
and at least conceptually there's one
master private key whether anybody has
it or whether we destroyed it when we
set the system up is a different
question but so in this model sort of
the see ISO has the master secret and
then in order for anybody to decrypt any
message they have to have some sort of a
secret
because and it's something that's not
generated by them because the process of
encrypting a message doesn't take any
input from the person you know the role
or whatever you're encrypting it to it
just uses the master public key so right
so so the answer is that Dave can't
generate his own key because nobody
listens to his input such as the role of
an engineer but so so he needs someone
to generate it for him and this this
hierarchy is the description of who can
generate keys for whom
and his public he is already well
defined as sort of like the combination
of the master public key and his name
before he has any input into the system
anyway so so so the the policies
participated in this partial order also
and so there's also there's there's a
transitivity of of these arrows so like
the CIS Oh clearly can create a key for
Carol she just creates a key for the VP
of Finance and then uses that key to
create a key for Carol directly it's not
like yes I actually give the key to the
VP of Finance and it may be that there's
there's a way to do this directly but
similarly the CIS ou can read everyone's
email and the VP of Finance can read
Carol's email and if you want to avoid
this it's possible you just sort of like
make another roll underneath the VP of
Finance that's sort of like the VP of
finances personal key and the other one
is like the VP of Finance is sort of
like escrow key and it's locked in to
save somewhere something like that but
anyway so this is this is the basic
model and then so what does it mean for
a design like this to be secure OS re
there a couple of other things that are
that are in this model so one of them is
collusion resistance this is sort of the
positive way of saying it but it means
that two people teaming up from this
diagram can't do anything other than
what they could do by themselves so for
example Dave and the VP of Finance
despite the fact that they've got a
finance person in an engineer they can't
read or mean that despite the fact that
they've got a VP and an engineer they
can't read the VP of engineering's email
for example by teaming up some some
systems actually do have some form of
collusion like you need certifications
from two different entities in order to
do something but in this case that's
that's verboten and then there's also
path independence so the model snippet
stipulates that any any
that you're doing within this model has
the property that Dave's key looks the
same whether no matter who generated it
so it could have been generated by the
VP of engineering or it could have been
generated by the C ISO directly and it
should look the same in either case it
should be from like the same
distribution of keys
and other situations
the real issue is just that it it
complicates the model and similarly the
decryption is sort of path independent
so the decrypting one of these messages
should have the same results no matter
who's doing the decrypting even if the
message is malformed and the advantage
of this is that when you talk about the
model you don't have to you you have a
smaller attack surface because instead
of attacking like trying to attack
Dave's key as generated by this path of
delegation versus his key is that
generated by this other path of
delegation you don't have to worry about
that and so well you don't have to worry
about you know decrypting a message with
this key instead of this other key it's
just mostly a formal thing if you one
day I one of the violence was anonymous
so that you will need this kind of
it's not enough anyway
I don't think you necessarily need this
property for anonymous encryption but it
does make the model a lot simpler in any
case so so like like with all crypto
systems this wouldn't be complete
without a security game which is what it
means for this system to be secure so
this is a game between an adversary
represented by FreeBSD and a challenger
which sort of represents the
functionality in the system that the
adversary might have access to and the
game sort of amounts to the adversary
shouldn't the adversaries goal is to try
to do something that he couldn't have
that he he shouldn't be allowed to do
within the functionality of the system
within the sort of explicitly provided
functionality of the system so the
Challenger sets up the system and sends
the public the sort of master public key
to the adversary and then the adversary
gets to make as many queries as he wants
and they can be of three different types
so he can choose any role in the system
and he and the Challenger will give him
a secret key for that role he can also
choose any ciphertext and say what
policy the ciphertext was encrypted
under and the Challenger will tell him
well will decrypt the the message for
him of course if the ciphertext was
malformed the Challenger might send him
back you know an error string or
something like that but yeah so he can
he can decrypt any message that he wants
even if he doesn't have the key for it
and then at one point during the game
any any point in this sequence of
queries he can choose a pair of policies
and a pair of corresponding messages and
the Challenger will flip a coin and
encrypt one of those policies or one of
those messages using one of those
policies and send the resulting
ciphertext back let's assume the
messages of the same length so we don't
have to get into that can of worms and
so the idea is that within the
functionality of the system the
adversary shouldn't be able to tell
which message was encrypted and under
which policy this is an anonymous
version
and at the end of the game after he's
possibly made more queries the adversary
guesses which what B is
and then he wins if he's correct except
that he doesn't win if he asked for a
secret key that's supposed to decrypt
one of the policies he requested because
in that case he's supposed to be able to
read the message and he doesn't win if
he asks the Challenger to decrypt the
challenged ciphertext because of course
in that case he's also supposed to know
what's in it and so the the security
property should be that the adversary
doesn't win this game much more than
half the time you know half plus Epsilon
so there there are variants to this
because there are several variants of
these models so one of the common ones
is that a lot of the schemes that are
designs in this area are selective
because it's very hard to prove things
in this full game and selective means
that the adversary has to know who he's
attacking before the game starts this is
a sort of realistic assumption and yes
to choose policy one in policy two in
advance
before he sees the public perimeters
yeah but the public perimeter still have
to be from the right distribution but
the the usual the usual reason for this
is that the Challenger sort of encodes
some hard math problem in the public
parameters in such a way that to open
one of the messages is equivalent to
solving the math problem or something
like that
a number of these these designs can't
handle anonymity so that means that you
can tell apart you can sort of tell
something about which policy a message
was encrypted with so in order to say
that the adversary doesn't learn
anything from this he should still be
able to not tell apart two messages
encrypted with the same policy so we
just say that the two policies are the
same
well because this is their more general
than just a name so the goal is to sort
of build on identity based encryption to
make a system where you can choose when
you encrypt a message a policy that
describes under what circumstances the
message can be read and so just saying
some subset of people should be yeses
I'll get there I mean I should've said
this earlier
and yesterday all of these if you can
prove security and their previous like
then it's a current or any of these yeah
but these are weaker notions of security
and another one would be that like maybe
you can maybe you can take a ciphertext
and like tweak it into another
ciphertext for the same message for
example so in that case the adversary
would if he gets to make decryption
queries for anything other than the
exact ciphertext you gave him then he'll
be able to sort of read the the message
but maybe maybe you say look okay you
can't make decryption queries after that
after you've been given the challenge or
maybe not even at all and so those are
also weaker notions of security so any
questions about the model before I move
on to the construction so so this this
model describes sort of all of these
different variants so the difference in
hierarchical is that in hierarchical the
the structure is a tree it's fixed to be
a tree of a specific shape and no other
setup
all those variants equivalent to you
nothin except there like this is a set
of Polish city so for example exactly
the policies which is just immediately
descendants of yes and yeah in which
which roles
yeah which roles in which policies they
support right so this is this is this is
an attempt to unify the definitions that
are used by the allow their allowable
roles and policies and I guess the how
weak the security model is but other
than that those are the only sort of
variables are you going to describe so
here is so here right so in this part
the policy language is completely
abstract and sort of the question that's
that's I'm about to deal with is what
sort of a policy language can you build
so for example you can build attribute
based encryption and then there's you
know whatever policy language Brent can
dream up and then but there yeah so the
toolbox that I'm going to describe to
build these things is something called
spatial encryption and the idea is that
the roles in this the things to which
you can assign keys are all this the
affine subspaces of an n-dimensional
vector space and you say that you've
given the key for for some space like
say a big plane you can you can create a
key for any space that is inside it like
any line it or point in that plane and
then the policies are points and the key
for a role which is some space can
decrypt a message encrypted to some
policy if the point lies inside that
space so this is a sort of abstract
notion but the idea is that if for every
role in your
hierarchy of roles you assign a subspace
and for every policy you assign a point
in such a way that the roles nest
appropriately and the policies are
inside the the right roles then this
will provide an implementation of the
the design that you want
well the policies are points yeah the
dimensions of the roles can be different
find subspaces okay so as you pointed
out this obviously captures a tree so
for example if you have a tree of depth
n and you have some sort of paths in
that tree then you just have the you
assigned to that the affine subspace
that has the first core you know K
coordinates fixed and the rest can be
anything so it was obviously an affine
subspace and similarly the policies are
the same things with the rest of the
coordinates set to 0 or to some fixed
value also you should notice here that
usually home is a string and not a
number so you need some way to encode it
as a number because you know mod mod P
or whatever and a collision resistant
hash function is enough I guess here
technically you need to be a collision
resistant hash function that never
outputs 0 but whatever so but you can
build other things besides HIV with it
so for example you can build broadcast
iv'e where every every message goes to
any sub subset of the users of size at
most I guess n minus 1 here where ends
the dimension of the space and the way
you do it is that you give Alice you
treat the the vectors in this space as
polynomials just you know as the
coefficients of polynomials or whatever
and you give to Alice all the multiples
of the poem of the polynomial X - Alice
so this is a vector subspace in fact and
then when you want to encrypt - you know
Alice Bob Carol then you just encrypt it
to the point X - Alice X - 5 X -
Caroline because polynomials uniquely
factorize then only Alice Bob and Carol
can read this message and they in fact
can read it because it's a multiple of
their because it lies in the space of
multiples of their name
that so Alice Alice is a string which we
hash to a number and then the the role
that she gets is corresponds to the
vector subspace which is all the
polynomials that are multiples of X -
Alice it's an N minus 1 dimensional
vector space
it's a co dimension yeah all polynomial
multiples not none scalar multiples yeah
these are all going to be much earlier
rates so is this I don't know whether
sort of geometrical framework is
something ad hoc made to make a security
groups work or whether for example
modular medicines are really smooth
generally
well so I don't actually know what a
modular lattice is but just more or less
the taken place and the geometrical
representation like this although you
may need slightly more general
representations to capture the whole
class
and we can talk more about it later so I
think an answer to your question is that
as long as the lattices are kind of
small then you can build them easily
using sort of any variety of known
techniques but when the lattices are big
so here like there's things parametrized
on on you know small sets of strings for
example then constructing them in
general is open and in fact probably
impossible because the description of
the lattice itself is going to be
exponentially large but it may be that
there are other classes of lattice that
would be interesting to build and could
be built that can't be captured in this
framework I I don't know how you would
design those I mean attribute based
encryption makes some things that don't
look like vector spaces as far as I know
but yeah this this does provide a sort
of a wide variety of possible lattices
to build that's sorry that's the maximum
number of users to which you can send a
single message
well general broadcasting pitch from
maybe it's kind of off but it's the
universe's potentially could be
exponential and you will want to
essentially give to everybody but like
white people so you can do that too but
that's there are different notions of it
so if this sort of broadcast ibe is
useful if you're sending an email for
example and you don't want to have a
separate ciphertext for each user but
rather one short ciphertext that sort of
captures all the people that the email
is addressed to as opposed to if you're
broadcasting a television show and have
some number of revoked keys from people
whose players have been compromised or
something like that
this is our desire our things and in
severe policies a polynomial so cialis
was read email
the actual mechanism is a little bit
abstract the point is that the policy
Alice or Bob or Carol maps to a point in
a vector space and Alice has a key that
reads any point in that in that in some
subspace of the vector space which
happens to contain the point Alice or
Bob or Carol
so how it works is that how is it best
to describe it well let me take this
offline if I've got time afterwards
the number of maximum users is more or
less unbounded but the maximum number of
users that you can send a single message
to is n minus 1 because the degree of
the polynomial is going to be right it's
P if you have a yes it's a it's a P it's
P if you want your hash function to be
by ejected but you know if it's just
collision resistant then the number of
you the users are just strings yes and
well and when you set up the n is fixed
when you set up the system no I and is
the dimension yeah right anyway the
other thing about this is that you can
use this to build broadcast HIV with a
sort of quick modification on this
scheme and this is the first sort of
construction of broadcast HIV e but you
have a question
okay yeah so there's there are a lot of
other things that you can do with this
so for example suppose that you're not
comfortable with the idea of the single
authority that can read everyone's email
so as you can see I gave this talk at
IBM before I give it here so suppose
that you have some authority let's say
that there Verisign and they move into
this business and they give a key to IBM
calm and then IBM gives keys to the
users who have email addresses there so
this is a sort of hierarchical ibe kind
of a design and in fact like I said in
the last slide we're doing broadcast HIV
e so you Alice has this message and she
wants to send it to Bob Carol and Dave
and they work at IBM and IBM and
Microsoft and she she also says in the
message which CAS that she trusts and
say that's Verisign CA cert or whatever
so then Bob and Carol can read this
because they have a key to the right
email addresses something on the on the
to list and something that was generated
by Verisign but if once again FreeBSD is
the enemy here if someone gets a key
that says Bob at IBM calm
that's not trusted the evil C is not on
the trust list then they won't be able
to use that key to read the message
because it doesn't it doesn't have the
the right properties so the the general
version of this is something called
product schemes and the goal is sort of
to add extra adjectives so here we're
adding multi Authority as the extra
adjectives to this scheme and the idea
is is actually quite simple so so the
the to field of this message is a
broadcast HIV e you know you choose you
choose multiple users in this sort of
hierarchy and so you can implement it in
CP to the end for some you know and that
you choose and then similarly the trust
setting is actually a broadcast
IBE because you're choosing a set of
different authorities just by the their
names and then so that you do that in zp
the M for some M where m is like the
maximum number of authorities +1 or
something like that that you want to be
able to specify at a time and then so
what when you when you have a role in
this system it is represented as a
vector subspace or I mean an affine
subspace of Z P to the N and an affine
subspace of Z P to the M so their direct
product is an fi and subspace of Z P to
the N plus m and similarly when you
encrypt you get a point in each side and
the the sort of pair of those is
appointed in Z p to the n plus m and it
turns out that this hierarchy actually
does what you want it to do which is it
sort of enforces this this and relation
here so each key has has one sort of
attribute from each each of the the
designs that your product and then you
you can delegate only if you can sort of
delegate on both sides so for example
ibm.com can delegate to Bob at IBM calm
and the HIV e design and then you know
Verisign can delegate to itself on the
broadcast I ve side and so so so this
you know this link is is allowed on the
other hand this link is not allowed
because while Bob at IBM calm the policy
the the HIV part of the policy this evil
CA doesn't read the the trust part of
the policy so this is not allowed
and it turns out that you can do this
much more generally so you in most cases
don't actually have to choose this nnm
ahead of time you have to choose sort of
the maximum dimensions allowed ahead of
time but you don't necessarily have to
choose it turns out how you're
partitioning the space and how you're
encoding everything ahead of time I'm
sort of continuing to explore that in my
work on policy languages for this but
yeah so so so so anyway yeah question
right so they're there sort of is
there's a there's a single super key
that's created when the system is set up
and then you divide it among all the
authorities and then you destroy it yes
or another thing that you could do is
you can use secret sharing and this is
compatible with secret sharing so you
can make it so that you know ten of the
most trusted authorities if eight of
them get to get that they can create a
new Authority for example and similarly
if eight of them get together they can
read anyone's email but it was
if I wanted to destroy that you don't
have to create all the authorities first
yes
which makes more sense if you're talking
about deploying this within a company
where you know you give each department
their secret key and then destroy the de
route or something like that can't do
infinity damage right so that's that's
actually sort of what I was saying about
collusion resistance so because a lot of
times the the multi authority schemes
are in fact by design not collision
resistant and so I can't even model them
so a quick note about how this is built
it's based on the Binet Boingo HIV II
and so the public parameters and the
secret keys are oh of n where n is the
dimension but the cipher texts are
constant size so in the initial
construction the cipher texts are
actually just two group elements so
they're forty or 64 bytes or something
like that and in the there's a sort of
enhanced version with a bigger security
proof or a better security proof where
the the cipher texts are a little bit
longer but only by a constant factor so
the the sort of enhanced security proof
is based on waters recent work in
particular the luca waters HIV ii and it
provides adaptive security which is the
strong notion it provides anonymous
security according to the definition but
not necessarily in practice because well
you can't determine who a message is to
based on i'm just looking at it you also
can't decrypt it without knowing who
it's to so there's it's sort of not
really anonymous in some sense
it's yeah you're saying there's there's
some of the property event a newbie
they'd like to
in some sense of the definition I should
I should probably put a note in the
thing I'm the definition of anonymity so
the the definition of anonymity and
that's usually given is that you can't
tell who a message is to by looking at
it sort of but the real question is then
can you decrypt it if it's to you and
usually an anonymous IBE
this is sort of a non-issue because you
only have like some small number of keys
and there's no hierarchy so you just try
all the keys but in the case where
there's a hierarchy this definition is a
little bit insufficient because you
can't you can't just try all the
possible policies that are below your
role in the hierarchy because there
might be exponentially many of them so
you subspace expansion points though
exactly even if it was one-dimensional
it would have P many points where piece
huge so unless it's a zero dimensional
which is possible the the definition of
anonymity is a little bit weak so maybe
I should change the security model to
point this out
role based thing is actually through the
people for I'm at some point and there
is a sacrilege suspect it's to some of
my descendants but I have no idea where
this is also exponential I can just test
I mean
these keeps the same who will say HIV
schemes I think there's an anonymous HIV
scheme out there I think
yeah it also has this deficiency yeah so
the security assumption for this is
static but like the leuco waters
assumption it's kind of nasty so i'd
like to improve it to something that's
less nasty but as it is it's some fixed
size but ugly thing there's a variant in
promoter groups I actually like the
variant promoter groups better because
despite the assumption being nastier you
don't also have to assume if factoring
is hard for example and you don't have
to have your group big enough that it
son factorable
unlike in Lugo waters or whatever where
it has to be huge
the original variant is prime orderer
and more efficient by a constant factor
but doesn't have a proof of adaptive or
anonymous security so there's a there's
a bunch of work left to do on this I
hope to have at least some of it done by
the time the thesis my thesis is due
which is in June or something like that
so I want I want to clean up the
Assumption change it into some nasty
thing with a million terms and some more
simple thing I have an idea about how to
fix the anonymity issue but almost sort
of necessarily at the cost of ciphertext
size because the thing about having
complicated policies and constant size
cipher texts is that the ciphertext
itself is certainly not enough to
determine what the policy was even if
you do have the key because there's just
it's not big enough and so at least with
the foreseeable way to fix this you'll
end up sacrificing ciphertext size if
you want to make use of that
there's a variant called Koh spatial
encryption where the policies are sort
of instead of being a point the policies
like also a vector space and you can
decrypt if it intersects this enables
you to build circuits and emulate sort
of more of attribute based encryption
you build like threshold gates and or
gates and stuff in a way that it's
harder to build with the regular design
here that the regular spatial encryption
unfortunately the the proof of security
at least in the interesting cases where
some components can be parallel to other
components is the the new adaptive fancy
dual system security proof hasn't worked
for it so if you don't if you don't want
to be stuck with selective security then
I need to improve that and then like I
said I haven't fully designed a policy
language I have some ideas for how to
make one but nothing final yet so I'd
like to sort of design a policy language
and then actually sit down and implement
this so that you know you can see how
fast it runs and how easy it is to use
so that's that's all then so any any
questions about this part of the talk
they'll get to the other part the other
part is just one slide so I've done some
some other work especially in the area
of implementing crypto systems so one
one thing is a fast and flexible
software AES this is the fastest
implementation of AES that doesn't use
Hardware instructions and that can do
sort of any mode there's a there's a
faster one if you want to do just
counter mode it works on power Mac and
on certain Intel chips it also works on
the more recent ones but they have
Hardware AAS so why bother and it's sort
of it avoids this attack where normally
you implement AES using big lookup
tables but there's an attack based on
sort of the fact that looking things up
in the lookup table alters the state of
the CPUs cache which means that an
attacker can sort of see what you are
looking up
I also did a JavaScript implementation
at AES it turns out that I think no
actual cryptographer had done this
before because I ended up with a very
small and fast one compared to what what
else is out there and then a recent
thing that I did was sort of silly
project to add crypto to video games to
make it harder to cheat in certain ways
and to do this because video games have
a lot of data that they shuttled back
and forth to do interesting crypto you
have to make it really fast and there's
some sacrifice of security but if the
games gonna last an hour then you know
it's it's fine if you make a key that
can only survive against a supercomputer
for six months
then so the big feature here is that
unlike say OpenSSL which takes almost a
millisecond to do an elliptic curve
group operation just takes about 12
microseconds so no it's four it's
actually oblivious set intersections so
the idea is that to prevent you from
seeing your opponent's units in a
real-time strategy game that aren't
actually in your field of vision you do
an oblivious set intersection of your
field of vision which is of course just
as secret as where your units are and
the locations of your opponent's units
and then based on the results of that
you know where his guys are that you can
see and not the ones that you can't see
it's a two party computation yeah sure
so you can cheat in other ways but the
idea is that at the end of the game all
is revealed the secrets are given away
and then your opponent can check by
emulating your view of the game I mean
his game will automatically check by
emulating your view of the game that you
didn't cheat but there's no way to sort
of automatically check at the end of the
game that you didn't siphon the memory
of the application and look at where
where his units are in memory which is
something that happens actually
surprisingly often in real-time strategy
games
because you can check at the end yeah
yeah so there's the partially ordered
set which is trying to tell us who can
delegate that Easter
simulator else there is the aspect of
the policies various saying there is a
broad class of things that can be done
but you don't have a an explicit
language for or it was despite exactly
what can be done so the the the model
part is trying to model other people's
work in the field and also this work in
general so there are many different
policy languages that people have built
so the model doesn't specify a policy
language it just says the roles and
policies are some partially ordered set
together they make a partially ordered
set yes it captures both the roles and
the policies and then what partially
ordered set depends on what design it is
and you're choosing
well so then the second the second part
of it I guess I didn't organize this
talk well enough the second part of it
the question is sort of how can we build
interesting partially ordered sets in
general so you can't build all of them
and in fact that ought to be impossible
to build every one of them because there
are too many of them but you can build
you know the following interesting class
of things that can be embedded in a
vector space of dimension and for some
end that you choose bound of n possible
users yeah and the actual public key is
linear in n yeah and also like you can't
really have a collision resistant hash
function into and it's into the domain P
so there are people there P total users
or something or there they're there any
number of total users but then there are
there only n that you can send a message
to at once in a single ciphertext yeah
or like or there's a there's a or n is
maybe the the the size of the the the
depth of the tree but then like at every
step it's like a Pieri tree where P is
huge so there's there exponentially many
positions in the hierarchy and it's
exponential in a huge number but the
exponent is only N and that's the the
depth is only in Genevieve's you have
been essentially exactly secret key well
kind of in the sense of the secret given
just under the scheme but just got my
Kiki yeah right then everybody cuz the
secret keeper to go into include 425
people so I'm gonna just you know if I
have to kind of things at all and it
could be quadratic for exists so if you
also wanted to have you know and
different authorities then it would be
like you need like N squared cipher
texts and then that yeah here's the
reverse which is a little bit easier to
deal with because you know if your
secret key takes a couple kilobytes on
disk then fine but you'd rather not
append a couple kilobytes to every email